[Music]
all right
i have an interesting story here
finally one that's interesting no okay
i'm gonna show you a photo and you guys
are gonna guess why are these guys in
the news
they were separated at birth separated
our birth
and then come to find out their twin
brothers they both stole golf clubs
you're getting closer in the
criminals are they russian i mean just
the photo looks like
they are not russian they were two
customers
trying to okay
to communists no two custard oh no
custom good no no no no custodians
no two [ __ ] no they tried to rob a golf
course but they didn't know where the
money was
two cousins yes cousins two
cousins cousin with hearts that beat us
one
and like i said criminal they did a
heist
oh that's sick what kind of heist money
a money heist furniture jewel heist oh
please be jewel heist
no no no no no no it's something weirder
that's why it's in a story
sewer caps they they stole sewer caps
what is that the the
let me just tell you the first piece
here is the fact that i do not know
their crime
oh but they but they did do something
else
made love no so what they did
are you done guessing they shot someone
i'm done no okay i'm sorry you just kept
pointing
okay so what ended up happening here is
these two cousin inmates
from italy they escaped prison
but they also they ended up leaving a
letter behind letting the
prison know like hey we had to go
because it was a family emergency we had
to go protect our
our children from uh from not getting in
trouble into some nasty business that we
got
ourselves into so we got to go protect
our children and then
there's no one else around to do this
because our wives are also in jail so we
have to take care of our family but
don't worry we'll we'll be back in 15
days
what damn they're so gangster xoxo
pretty much here's here's a fiver for
the for pizza
wait they broke out of jail and they
wrote a letter saying we just gotta
we'll be right back
pretty much so what ends up okay so
they're saying that they were
currently serving sentences due to end
in 2029
and i lied i do know what their crimes
were it was for non-violent crimes
including fraud and receiving stolen
goods
that's what they got caught for but they
didn't but then they got lots of dirt on
them
yes how'd they escape from jail yeah oh
that's my favorite [ __ ]
yeah okay so they managed to escape by
cutting through the bars on their prison
cell window rattling down into a
courtyard on a fire hydrant
water hose and climbing over the outer
walls by climbing the barbed wire
with a rot wire cutter wow i didn't even
cut the bar in the first place
with the wire cutter wire cutters up
their butt [ __ ]
hose up their butt fire hose up their
butt this is something like
crazy italian matcha like
we gotta keep training our [ __ ] for
this [ __ ] i'm not ready to get these
wire cutters up there yet
exactly so now police are
looking for these guys they don't trust
them they say they're kind of bad
if you can escape prison that's that's
you should be
set free i think so that's like the game
like if you get out yeah and i feel like
if someone's in jail for a non-violent
crime and they escape
let them go yeah well the thing is here
that they are facing a five-year
extension to their sentence because they
escaped prison
if i heard that i'm like i'm not coming
back then exactly that's exactly the
reason why cops are looking for them
right now because they're like they're
not going to come back
but dude we're going to come back here
we are yeah
they're mobsters they're honorable they
are going to come back they should say
hey you come back we'll give you it will
honor your sentence
and then the guys come back and like nah
you're getting five more years
why would they say that exactly why
would they say that
but also like i mean if they come back
they should be rewarded by not getting
the five years they should have at least
waited until 15 days after
yeah no because they they've already
gotten so by the time that they
discovered that they had escaped there
was already a three hour head start
from the moment that the cops realized
so then they're like [ __ ] every hour
counts like we're not going to let give
them 15 days
what knows what they're gonna be doing
how much time did they have left in
their sentence
ending 2029 remember well that is a good
excuse to say like hey i'm coming back
right so don't look for me
to have a 15 day head start like hey if
i say i'm gonna come back maybe they
won't look
yeah but yeah that's that's these guys
crazy i love stories like these i was
watching this video about this japanese
guy
i don't think he committed any crime but
they were pinning it on him and he was
in this jail zone he actually managed to
break out of it
um and he broke out like out of several
different jails and each yell he went
into it always got like
buffer security buffers this is bronson
because this isn't bronzing
he's japanese bronze sun
forgot the japanese part yeah and then
choppo did that a bunch too
yeah so there's one method where um he
was given a like a bowl of miso soup and
so instead of drinking it he'll like
spill some onto the bar so they start
rusting what
they rust like he just [ __ ] busted
out of there tight
i'm too fat for that i don't want to
lose my food like yo you guys need to
get better security
and i'm gonna continue breaking out of
these until until i die
you like rock it yeah from guardians of
the game that should be a profession
like you're in jail and
just to teach security to them and like
where they can improve same with hackers
like
government agencies hire hackers like
they call them white hats i guess
and then like they help like beef up the
security because it's like here are the
holes
patch them yeah they're always smart
who's that guy that escaped from
was it alcatraz where um he had like
made a plaster thing on his head yeah
their heads and they left them in the
beds to make it seem like that was the
clint eastwood movie
was it escape from alcatraz yeah word
true story though sick movie
we still have like the model at alcatraz
i went on the tour like a female i went
on
tour too it was dope pretty cool would
you um
want to say you have a 10 year sentence
like be put in a coma for 10 years or be
in prison
coma i vote coma really because you're
just waiting
older yeah but but then you don't get to
live your life in prison
oh [ __ ] that is that punishment if i
just go to sleep and wake up
well you do lose 10 years of real life i
guess i guess it isn't same with prison
but people always get buff in prison
yeah they come out looking cool and they
get smart sometimes yeah
you got [ __ ] to do but read you can live
a life in prison
yeah make some friends i feel like for
the for the jail system they probably
make more money
keeping them in a coma because that's
what they really want and then they
don't learn
while being in prison so they commit the
crime again so they could get back in
jail
and make more money it's probably so
expensive to keep somebody in the coma
though because you gotta give them a
feeding tube and all that [ __ ] yeah but
that's what they want they wanna
giving them a live suit like regular
like healthy
prisoners yeah it's like 30 or 40 g's
per inmate every year
[ __ ] crazy support it's like all
those contracts too because we have a
friend that like
works with them so they basically say if
some guy comes in overnight right
um they get that contract for that one
person even though he's gone the next
day
they still the government has to pay
that prison ten thousand dollars
whoa yeah really yeah just for booking
them
yeah well they're supposed to like that
ten thousand supposed to cover them for
like uh
like 180 days or something but since
they go on once it counts as that
um contract a part of it i think i'd
rather be awake
because i can make friends work out
learn arts and crafts mm-hmm
you would do well in prison you would do
very well and you would want to
experience like when you're finally free
that like rush it's like not having sex
for like
a year and then finally having something
oh you're gonna have sex in there
[Laughter]
you're gonna you're gonna get sex in
there not having sex you're gonna get it
for sure
actually julia's cut out for prison she
can handle being in prison
think so too you got it okay there's got
to be some people up in there
dude she's strong i went like out of
yeah all you guys that came training
with us
she was the strongest oh yeah oh no i'm
not strong
jk yeah well she just started maxing out
they had a plate on everything
like two plates on dead lift this is how
scary she is dude
that was long bart i felt like bart was
gonna
kill me that day when i was doing
deadlifts to test my
so remember that time when everybody in
jk was going to the gym right and then
you know how we
we both asked bart hey bart can you make
us a plan um
and barbara was like yeah sure sure just
come to the just come to the gym i need
a test for your maxes right
and so you did your max right and then i
just remember on the day that i came to
do my max
like bart just saw and he was like we're
gonna add another 10 plates
and then i would do it and i'm like okay
this is my max he's like
we're just getting 10 he needs to see
you on the brink of death
yeah exactly and he kept adding plates
on and then jill was like
babe you're gonna kill her he's like
yeah she got it five more players world
potential world champion potential and
i'm like that's insane
and nobody would [ __ ] with you in prison
give me less weight and i'll act like
it's way more weight
i wish i'd have known that i wish i had
known that but i think for meals like
i'm all about trying to improve
and so then at that point when i was
dead lifting i don't
i don't know what two plates is it was
over 200 pounds
and then your boyfriend at the time was
like i could do it and he goes up to it
he's like
oh i'm a backpack oh i could do it i
could do it i could do it any other day
that's even worse you know what the
preface was so like
as soon as like those two plates came on
to the bar bart went up to me he's like
have you ever worn a belt before and i
was like no and he's like you're gonna
wear one right now and i was like what
why protecting you i know you're
protecting me but i was just like i've
never gone to a weight that high before
and as soon as i like lifted it up i
just saw [ __ ] stars yeah
like i almost blacked out and i was just
like oh i feel like my back was going to
snap into and bart was like
yeah it's like more weight more places i
can't do it
i remember we did uh so i did two videos
with y'all training me right and then
the first one where you were making me
do that what are the tip thrusters
the monsters bro and you have so many
and the next day my [ __ ] ass and i
love chilling stories
oh she like on her i just thought it's
like me like crawling on the ground
but i mean i looked great
[Music]
you